thanks to trade coffee for keeping legal
eagle in the air cuz you would not want
to see me before my first cup of joe am
i right alright let's watch Tiger King
again don't record your lawyer do not
record your lawyer without permission I
cannot emphasize that highly enough
[Music]
hey all you cats and kittens I mean
legal eagles I told you this one almost
broke me but you guys had a lot of
unanswered questions just when I thought
I was out you pulled me back in but I
wanted to cover some of the other things
that I left out in the original real
lawyer reacts to Tiger king some of the
other crimes committed allegedly
allegedly in the documentary and some of
the other crimes that the characters
definitely committed off-screen look if
Joel McHale can squeeze out in an 8th
episode of tiger king with an iPhone and
air pods in his ears the whole time we
can do a second episode of real lawyer
reacts so without further ado let's dig
in to tiger King again for some reason
the last day that I saw it on he told me
that he was done that he was divorcing
her that she was one of the worst people
that ever met in his life and she was
very dangerous he indicated to me that
he was going to tell Carol that he
wanted a divorce never saw him again ok
so right off the bat probably the
biggest question I got was did I think
that Carol Baskin committed murder on
this channel I tend to avoid trying to
make judgment calls like these when not
all of the facts are known sometimes I
will go out on a limb and I will give my
opinion as to whether I think a crime
was committed or whether a lawsuit is
meritorious or not but almost always
that's in cases where most of the facts
if not all the facts are known like for
example a copyright case where I can
look at the allegedly infringing piece
of art and the original piece of art and
I don't need to know more facts than
that and that's really all that's
relevant in a copyright case for example
but here the
is a one-sided documentary with an
agenda I don't know that anyone can
really open on this I will say that in
doing more research for this episode in
the prior episode there's a lot more
information about Dawn's medical
diagnosis about his Alzheimer's and his
bipolar disorder there's a lot more in
terms of the conservatorship cases
between him and his former family so
there are a lot of facts out there that
are not in a documentary that I think
are probably relevant here that I think
paint things in a different light and
the documentary needs to have equal
parties opposing each other for
narrative purposes you need to have a
good guy and a bad guy or a bad guy and
another bad guy of relatively equal
power and that lends to the narrative so
I would say if you're interested in this
check out Carol Baskins retort to the
documentary she puts out a lot of
additional facts out there it's on the
big cat rescues website and judge for
yourself but I don't think it's my place
to opine on whether I think Carol Baskin
killed her her former husband I will say
though that between Joe and Carol Baskin
only one of those people is in federal
prison and with a potentially life
sentence to serve out so you know take
that as you will and you decide who
deserves the benefit of the doubt
they're filming reality show he blew up
so bad when I showed him that contract
he was like you don't own me I said Joe
actually I do right now I do own this
show I do own it don't record your
lawyer do not record your lawyer without
permission I cannot emphasize that
highly enough there's really no reason
for Joe to have recorded this in the
first place number one if you record it
and then you show it to somebody else
you are waiving the attorney-client
privilege you are removing
confidence of the discussion between you
and your attorney and therefore third
parties can get access to the things
that you discussed during that meeting
on top of that without permission if
this is a one-party consent state you
might be violating their right to
privacy on top of that you have evidence
that is bad for both of you because if
indeed the lawyer is suggesting that you
go out and commit a crime that might
qualify as conspiracy to commit arson
lawyers have an ethical obligation to
inform law enforcement when they know
that a crime is going to be committed so
that goes beyond the the realm of
attorney-client privilege in the first
place now obviously we don't know
exactly what's going on here this
footage I think is pretty chopped up
it's meant to imply that something that
various is going on between Joe and his
attorney so we don't know exactly what
was discussed but the implication is
that the lawyer is suggesting that he go
out and commit arson there's no
attorney-client privilege is going to
attach when you actively suggest to a
client that they go out and commit a
crime there are very very very big
problems here that building where the
alligators were kept as well as a studio
that Joe had it was clearly an arson it
was a set fire a man burns so hot there
was nothing left
I dropped my knees and I cried okay just
as I am NOT going to opine on whether I
think Carol Baskin killed her former
husband I'm not going to apply non who I
think committed the arson here this is I
think based on what is shown in the
documentary clearly an act of arson it
doesn't seem like there's any natural
reason why this thing would catch fire
and there are people with definite
motives as to why they might commit
arson what I will say though is that if
one sets fire to their own property
intentionally that still qualifies as
arson so you can't just go around
torching your own stuff because
obviously that can create negative
externalities and you might catch your
neighbor's alligator enclosure on fire
as well so we don't want all of their
stuff burning down too so if you set
fire to your own
barn that qualifies as arson don't do
that
so I'm doctor Bhagavan Antal bhag avian
Antal aant le doctor bhargavan antal
okay let's talk about doc antal there
are two really interesting things about
doc Hansel number one is that everyone
was curious about potential sexual
harassment claims based on the sort of
implied cult-like behavior at this
institution if they wanted to get to the
top really quickly they should sleep
with him in general there are two kinds
of a sexual harassment there's quid pro
quo or sexual harassment and then
there's hostile workplace environment
quid pro quo is do something of a sexual
nature for me and you will either be
rewarded or you'll be punished if you if
you don't do this he controlled every
aspect of our day what we were allowed
to do what we were you know definitely
what we were allowed to eat he does
vegetarians but also they were pushing
me to get implants and then the hostile
work environment is using the basis of
sex to create some hostile work
environment and you can imagine that if
you are pressuring women to have plastic
surgery that could certainly give rise
to a hostile work environment and give
rise to a sexual harassment claim now
the other really interesting thing about
doc antal is that his compound in South
Carolina was raided by the police in
December of 2019 now antal claims that
the warrants had to do with tracing
liens that ended up in his institution
that came from a park of very ill repute
and that the the police were just simply
trying to track down information related
to somebody else the police are not
saying why it is that they raided his
park as you can imagine they are not
likely to comment on an ongoing
investigation but it's sort of up to you
as to whether you think that it's
related to Doc antle's own improper
conduct regarding animals or it's
related to somebody else or both but
again we don't have all the facts here
it doesn't show stock in it doesn't show
battery it doesn't show anything it
shows a verbal argument
and that's not enough to get an
injunction and so that's why you think
it was tonight that's why I know it was
did I but all of this that was dead on
arrival
what raised my eyebrows is she
threatened to kill me that's not enough
together nope I was free speech there's
free speech we don't restrain free
speech in this country we punish it
after it's done got a lot of questions
about Dawn's attempt to get a
restraining order and the attorney's
comments that it was just free speech so
we we punish speech after the fact
instead of getting restraining orders
ahead of time and that's it's half it's
very half right it's maybe a quarter
right now first of all in Florida you
can get a domestic restraining order and
it doesn't require an actual act of
physical abuse and in Florida
restraining order is generally known as
an injunction for protection it's a
civil court order but if you violate
that order that can lead to a criminal
offense it does not require violence you
can get it if there are there's a
history of abuse or there are they're
real credible threats and generally
speaking there's a thing under First
Amendment law called a true threat which
is not protected by the First Amendment
so you can't go around making true
threats to people and thinking that
you're going to escape liability so it
is possible for Dawn to get a
restraining order under these
circumstances but you can imagine where
that is simply generalized threats it
would be difficult oh and speaking of
restraining orders Don wasn't the only
one who wanted to get a restraining
order
Joe's ex-husband John Finley has a
history of some criminal activity
including in 2014 he was arrested for
domestic assault and battery when he
reportedly attacked Joe although he was
never charged and months later in
October of 2014 Finley filed for a
protective order against Joe but that
protective order was also dismissed
because he failed to meet his burden of
proof and in September of 2018 the
mother of his young daughter filed for a
petition for a protective order against
John Finley himself so a lot of
protective orders going around a lot of
potential assault battery so real
the sad situation unfortunately with
Jeff flow coming in to help him Joe
believed that if he just convinced us
that he had endless resources to keep
lost of going we would suddenly fold our
tent and go away which of course we were
not going to do my lawyers recommended
that we just dissolved the pier aluminum
Soup Company
ah Jeff Lowe what can be said about Jeff
Lowe I would have thought he'd dressed
really cool in 1997 so initially when I
saw this potential investment from Jeff
flow into Jo's zoo it sounded like
another fraudulent transfer we talked
about in the prior episode about the
fraudulent transfer between Jo and his
mother Shirley Shri Vogel which we know
it was a fraudulent transfer because she
admitted as much he was trying to hide
his assets by putting them in the name
of somebody else
which you know don't do that so if you
want to hear all about that fraudulent
transfer check out real lawyer reacts to
Tiger king part 1 I'll put a link in the
description but it sounded like Jeff
Lowe was doing the exact same thing he
was taking title to the zoo
and in an effort to prevent Caryl Baskin
from getting the assets of the zoo it
seems like he's done more than that
though it sounds like he's made a
material investment into the zoo itself
I don't have all the facts here but it
sounds like this maybe more bonafide
than the transfer to Joe's mother so I
don't think we can necessarily say Jeff
Lowe committed a fraudulent transfer
here at scene and given that he's
actively running the zoo itself he had
to make some sort of investment it's
hard to do but it's not impossible to
invest in distressed assets like this
without it being a fraudulent transfer
he decided he wants to stay in Vegas and
try and make money out there he talked
to sponsor into buying a bus and they
called it the jungle bus
like a party bus with animals why they
haul people from casino to casino and
then play with Cubs while they're doing
it we thought it would be a good idea
but we were wrong that was a big mistake
huh yeah so even if we give Jeff Lowe
the benefit of the doubt with respect to
the GW Zoo I'm not sure we can give him
the benefit of the doubt with respect to
his Vegas business according to court
documents mr. Lowe faces open court
cases in Las Vegas Municipal Court where
he's accused of doing business without a
license in 2017 and failing to obtain a
license or permit for wild or farm
animals so I can't imagine why adding
big cats to a shuttle service for drunk
Vegas tourists wouldn't work out seems
like a really really bad investment but
a good investment would be to subscribe
to this channel in fact I was checking
my google analytics and only 30 percent
of the people that watch this channel
are subscribed to this channel so please
subscribe if you like this content and
if you click the notification bell I'm
in the comments for the first hour after
I release a video so you can ask me all
the rest of the crazy questions we have
about Tiger King my life and it probably
won't surprise you to learn that Jeff
Lowe also has pleaded guilty to mail and
wire fraud Seth you identify as a man
were you upset when they kept referring
to you as she on the show I don't think
it bothered me as much as it bothered
everyone else I didn't really pay it any
mind
okay let's talk about saff apparently in
the original documentary the
documentarians misgendered saff I was
using female pronouns and apparently
that's not correct so I apologize for
that miscommunication I guess that was
cleared up in the 8th episode which I
hadn't seen by the time that I did the
first episode of real lawyer reacts but
regardless saff is a pretty tough cookie
given that that they were able to get
back to work
after getting their arm ripped off who
would you trust first again Joe exotic
or the tiger who bit your arm off the
tiger sap also has a bit of a checkered
history including being arrested at
least eight times by the the Garvin
County Oklahoma Sheriff's Department
including charges for DUI carrying
weapons obtaining goods with a false
premise and a failure to appear for
warrants so yeah tough cookie
and a checkered history as well well Joe
came to me one day to saw the blue he
says you think Alan could kill somebody
I said is he capable of it mister of
course who's not I'll cut her head off
for you people and he was all into that
I said you would you like me to bring it
back no now get rid of it in a swamp
okay he'll do Frank
Alan Glover seems like such a normal
nice guy a lot of people had questions
about his plea deal and his prior
history
Alan Glover has been arrested at least
20 times including DUI domestic violence
possession of drugs and assault and
battery like you name it this guy has
basically been accused of it so given
this guy's past history they were
surprised that he was not charged in the
same conspiracy to murder
that's the Jo exotic was and prosecutors
and US Attorney's have a lot of leeway
in terms of who they will charge and why
and cooperating with the government is a
great way to get a reduction in your
sentence to get a reduction down to
suspended probation or sometimes not
being even even charged at all now it's
a weird interplay between the way that
this works in the federal system where
there are sentencing guidelines that try
as you might the prosecutors have less
leeway in terms of being able to forgive
people based on their cooperation with
government now the way that they tend to
get around that is that instead of
saying you were charged with conspiracy
to commit murder and we're only going to
give you probation for that the
generally doesn't work under the
sentencing guidelines they simply only
charge him with a lesser included crime
something that can be pled down to no
jail time or some other suspended
sentence so I suspect that is what
happened here that they just simply
didn't charge him with the same crime
that Joe xotic was charged with and they
went for the maximum penalty for Joe
exotic because he was the sort of
mastermind and the the one that they
really wanted to take down based on the
egregious nosov his behavior you forced
my name 20 just in that 12 months while
he was running for the governor
Oklahoma we found I think 88,000 some
dollars in misappropriated spending do
you want it's wrong it might surprise
you to learn that Joe's campaign for
governor of Oklahoma was not on the up
and up under Oklahoma law you are not
allowed to use corporate funds to fund
an individual run for political office
so really using the funds of the GW Zoo
for his ill-fated campaign for governor
is basically just embezzlement in
Oklahoma corporations are prohibited
from making contributions to candidates
PACs and party committees but they can
make unlimited contributions to ballot
measures if Joe in fact did use any
corporate funds of the GW Zoo for his
own political campaign above limits
definitely the campaign finance
violation and speaking of Joe's run for
governor of Oklahoma let's talk about
his campaign manager Josh dial I was
Joe's campaign manager for about a year
and a half and it was a worst experience
of my life it was horrible horrible
horrible
now although josh was the relative voice
of reason throughout this show he has a
checkered past including a 2017 felony
assault and battery the affidavit that
was sworn out against him states that
dial cut stabbed or slashed I presume
his boyfriend with a Japanese ninja
sword katana the victim had an 11
centimeter laceration and the victim was
sent to the hospital via emergency air
evacuation if only there had been a
warning sign that seemingly normal Josh
dial might not be as well adjusted as we
thought I'm a libertarian so technically
the feds all right so let's tally up all
the crimes starting with Joe he was
sentenced to 19 different counts his
sentence included a hundred and eight
months for each of the two
murder-for-hire counts totaling two
hundred and sixteen months he got 12
months for each of the Endangered
Species Act violations and 14 months for
the Lacy's Act violations all to run
concurrently now regarding all of the
other characters in Tiger King they're
just simply too many crimes to camp so
I'm not even going to
alright let us never talk about Tiger
King again because I need a drink no I
need I need something stronger than this
like trade coffee trade is great because
not only do they have a huge selection
of your favorite coffees but they have
an awesome quiz to get matched the
coffee recommendations based on your
taste preferences I don't actually drink
coffee every day but when I do like when
I have to force myself to get through
eight hours of legal insanity involving
big cats and crazy people I want my
coffee to actually taste good and with
trade you can discover new coffees from
the nation's top Roasters trade matches
you with your own personal selection of
coffee and conveniently delivers it to
you and let's just say that you're
watching eight hours of tiger king
hypothetically and that drove you to
start drinking at 10 o'clock in the
morning my life well they could probably
match a coffee for that as well
now the first 100 legal eagles will get
30% off their first bag when they sign
up and you get free shipping just click
on the link in the description take the
quiz choose your frequency whether you
want one bag or a subscription and then
rate your coffee so your suggestions get
better over time and you can even choose
whole beans or your preferred grind it's
really the best coffee website out there
so to get 30% off of your first order
click on link in the description or use
the promo code legal 30 at checkout
clicking on that link really helps out
this channel so do you agree with my
analysis of Tiger king leave your
objections in the comments and check out
this playlist over here with all of my
other real lawyer reactions including my
prior reaction to Tiger king of all the
other things I didn't cover here today
so click on this link and I'll see you
in court